i wouldn't be opposed to if
if we're going off those if we're going
off that guideline then it can be said
for the opposite agenda i think i think
men and women are different but um
i think a higher value woman
doesn't necessarily can't necessarily
exist without a high value man by her
side i personally think what one one
because
because the things that were listed out
those are for that's what makes a man
valuable to a woman
but what makes a woman valuable to a man
are not those things that are listed out
why can't she be
because
because a high value man like if we're
being a high value man a guy with money
a guy with his things together he's
putting his life together he doesn't
care how much a woman makes no it's true
but i think i to be fair i think the
spectrum will be slightly different for
women because
things are going to be seen different as
a guy like guys do guys have a role in
society they got to do certain things
and females have a certain role in
society and they're going to do certain
things so within their role whatever's
there
you get me whatever's there big thing
that's what's going to make them high
value like guys i'll if we go with just
the um broad spectrum of guys provider
xyz girls um the nurturing type so just
on the broad spectrum doesn't have to be
too deal but i would say within that
sector whatever brings a female up there
cool that's what makes them high value
and whatever set on the guy side will
make them high value being the network
and net worth and 10 um thousand pounds
a month whatever that translates to in
the female side that's what made them
into a a higher value woman in it i
think that's what it is what do you
think jess um going off of what you said
how
women can't be
and
um
is essentially what a man sees could
what i'm thinking is like couldn't a
woman be high value by herself and be
considered high value because that
definition i mean
maybe in the echo chambers of women like
she'll be considered high value she's
got her own business together and she's
independent if she's strong like you
know someone like
i don't even know who to oprah yeah
do you understand like but men aren't
learning up to date exactly
you know what i think personally i would
give if i had to give someone a high
value like a woman who's high value i'll
probably say lebron's james wife yeah
that's what i'll say lebron james his
wife she's probably a high value woman
do you know he was just a higher woman
do you think she could be a high value
woman over 30
no but like i think i think she's a high
value woman because of kind of like the
antics that she showed you you're never
gonna see her
like half naked on the gram you're never
gonna see her embarrass
lebron james on the internet you're
never gonna see her do anything to kind
of like jeopardize the james name kinda
so that's how that's what i would
consider like that makes her kind of a
high value i agree with him saying that
i don't think i slightly don't think
that a female could be high value
without a guy because like
go ahead giggle yeah cause it's like
end of the day
if we talk about people like you said
oprah she got all the stuff and ordered
some achievements and qualifications and
we're basing it off like the stuff that
she's gotten would be
somewhat towards like a a guy's thing
like she has all this um
money and all this network and network
for next one i said and that's more on
the guy's person that like if guys look
guys you're like yeah god like yeah
she's she's doing her thing yeah you
know what i'm saying like she's a
billionaire
they don't want to screw it exactly yeah
that's the thing like they're they're
full like on a on a in a guy's lens yeah
she's high value but that's not the type
of girls that we're gonna go for do you
get what i'm saying like therefore like
on the female spectrum i don't think
she'll be high value but on a on a male
spectrum she'll be i think it's flipped
i think on the female stretch him she'll
be high value i don't think so because i
think i cannot think so females look at
money and accomplishments as high value
on a guy i think women have an innate
understanding where we we know who's the
most like desired girl in our friend
group i think we we can break each other
all the time
and
i don't i think girls are capping when
they when they think their money adds
something because men just aren't
attracted to that yeah i don't yeah i
can't lie that's a fact yeah some women
don't realize that like
men don't care you get what i'm saying
girls be thinking oh cause i got big
bucks and we too like oh yeah he's gonna
think i'm just nah that's not even how
it goes so to go off what you said about
oprah and men
don't want to bang her or nothing
what about a woman
that is a billionaire that dudes want to
such as rihanna
would you not consider her a high-value
woman no she's for the streets
i would have watched three i don't know
see what that meant oh the wi-fi i'll
definitely be
drake's been there asaps they're even
some unknown saudi arabia king yeah he's
been there
but you gotta be real now you gotta be
you're that's just that i think that's a
personal thing i can't even lie to you
like because
unless your wife rihanna i don't know
she's got a ute now as well no the use
in the picture i can't lie unless that
changes you won't have to take care of
it no no i heard that but that's a whole
different you're to have to play a role
regardless that you're in the picture
now like that's a whole different
dynamic on this obviously you're getting
twisted in real life if rihanna said
you'll come like what that means
she's got bread at that moment oh sorry
my birthday
at that moment in time people will learn
how to fly to her wings will prepare the
back of their backs i'm telling you but
i don't like if what you wouldn't go
with rihanna
like i wouldn't take her serious i
wouldn't be like yeah this is my wife
like because it
that's reality
but what makes you say
one at a time
obviously hypothetically i'll be like
like i would want to be with her and
whatnot like because she's buff it's
rihanna you get me but
in reality would would that be my future
wife and whatnot like come on we've got
also look at what men value we value
loyalty and respect
so therefore the loyalty aspects
rihanna's been with a bunch of guys and
you can tell you she's been faithful to
them but like
what's going on in those relationships
that is is not leading
to
a long term her getting her ready
didn't she beat up chris brown like
wasn't that mutual it came out later
yeah yeah those yeah
exactly
but with that being said like
you go through relationships or the end
of the day you're first related well
more or less your first relationship
isn't going to be the the first one that
goes you're going to have to go for door
number one door number two you've done
number three before you get to the all
right this is the final door this is the
house that i'm going in this is the keys
and that's why i said what i'm saying
would you say that rihanna has dated men
that you would class as high value in
society
so my point is
if a woman's goal is to attain the
highest valuable man in society and
rihanna is running through the high
value men in society and not being able
to keep them
what does it mean for you
all right i hear you going that far
i know what does it say about what then
yeah
exactly
i hear you on that part but to also flip
the coin it's like like i said your fur
you just cause you go through several
high value men if you put it down on
this plane this on this plane is um
um on the plane aboard men are still men
at the end of the day like you're gonna
go through one guy regardless the first
high value man might not be the f the
good one whatever whatever
compatibilities that it might be do you
understand that you might have to go
through several high value guys before
you find your right high value guide you
get what i'm saying you're talking from
a man's perspective that's okay for a
man to think i'm gonna go through
several women yeah until i find my woman
it's not the same for a woman it's not
the same can you guys take an input on
that like if if
if what he's saying is correct
well i mean what do men value men value
purity that's why like when i when i
talk to men and by and large they say
they would prefer a girl with a lower
body count versus